the Seward Highway is the main
thoroughfare for the Kenai Peninsula
this highway is one of Alaska's
deadliest stretches of roadway and is
most common major accident is a head-on
collision it's mid-may and thousands of
tourists on an unfamiliar two-lane road
is a major concern it seems like we have
more fatalities on the road in the
summer time it seems like they don't pay
attention because it's just beautiful
down here throughout his career Petersen
has responded to dozens of fatal
collisions and knows all too well the
repercussions of speeding or negligent
driving this is where she goes flying
off that's where she ends up right there
sometimes you get there and everyone's
already dead sometimes you get there and
they're not you know they're dying in
the car you can't get them out doors
just won't open with a crowbar and
you're the only one there on scene and
it's just the worst thing about weather
today's no different
just ran over a motorcycle
get back
trooper Peterson races to the scene of a
head-on collision between a motorcycle
and the semi-truck
on occasion my first party in law
network by partner
witnesses witnesses you the caller are
you David yeah I'm Dave how you doing
David I'm trooper Peterson where's the
girl young I was she the victims being
rushed to the hospital with critical
head injuries is she gonna die
we don't know yeah I we haven't really
they struggling took her we haven't seen
her okay but we know it's serious
physical injury all of a sudden in the
midst of all these bikes one of them
goes I think they went out and back in
but the way too quick and then once they
went back in they went down and she was
ejected oh boy who was driving the bike
I don't
I think according to the driver of the
semi he came around a bend to see a
group of bikers traveling in a pack in
both the southbound and northbound lanes
one of the bikers swerved to avoid a
collision and threw his passenger off
the bike and into oncoming traffic
yeah he's slowing down the right he
thinks that she he ran over her head
with the last second last axle in this
couple marks on the outside of tyre the
victim's husband remains on the scene to
speak with police can she had got
someone I think she did someone's in the
hospital now so now becomes I mean it
could certainly be a death investigation
here in an hour
the truck driver is shaken up but
willing to help with the investigation
any way he can
is distraught he thinks he saw you know
a woman go underneath his tire there's
rear tire and he's pretty upset about
that although some sleep
nothing I could do about it though I
couldn't get away from her you know I
think I think she slid into my tires but
there's nowhere for me to go nothing for
me to do the situation looks grim
trooper Peterson prepares for the worst
and shuts down the highway first shut it
down okay yeah we got total station come
then this could be a death investigation
so we're treating it as such